[Music]
thank you
hello it's 12 o'clock and we start with
breaking news on the BBC crisis the BBC
director General confirms neither he nor
the unnamed presenter were approached
about explicit picture allegations until
seven weeks after the first complaint
the BBC boss also admitted the
corporation must learn lessons about how
complaints are red flat
Tim Davey also confirmed the BBC has
spoken to the Metropolitan Police about
the claims which the Prime Minister says
are shocking and concerning
foreign
good afternoon welcome to Sky News today
with Nick Karachi let's start with that
breaking news then the director general
of the BBC has admitted the corporation
must learn lessons about how complaints
are red flagged after it emerged no
senior executive or even the presenter
in question was told about the
allegations until seven weeks after they
were made now in the past hour the
corporation's boss answered questions
about the presenter Scandal which is
rocking the organization at a timeline
was released confirming who knew what
inside the BBC and when so what have we
learned let's find out on the 18th of
May it said a family member attended a
BBC building and tried to make a
complaint about the unnamed presenter
well then the following day the
complainant contacted audience services
that complaint was passed to the BBC's
corporate investigations team that
investigations team decided there was no
criminal allegation but that the claims
did need further investigation but got
no response it said to an email sent to
a family member on June the 6th a phone
call was made to the complainant but did
not connect no further attempts were
made to make contact
a month later it is said the son
informed the BBC about the allegations
which were different in nature to the
original claims now this was the first
time the director general or any
executive directors at the BBC were
aware of the case
a senior manager had the first
conversation with the presenter that day
and it was agreed that the presenter
would not be on air
the next day the BBC's investigations
team then contacted the complainant
again and the BBC made contact with the
police the presenter was suspended on
Sunday
and yesterday BBC bosses met with police
to discuss the investigation and they
have now paused their inquiry while the
police look into the claims
okay Plenty to digest Let's cross live
to our arts and entertainment
correspondent Katie Spencer outside the
BBC's new broadcasting house so plenty
to chew over what have you learned
yeah look bear in mind this was supposed
to be a briefing on the BBC's annual
report all of the QA was almost entirely
dominated by journalists wanting some
clarity from the BBC's the answers to
the questions that we're all asking and
I'm not entirely sure that we're any
clearer as a result of that
um Tim Davey director General uh firstly
started by saying because the Met police
are assessing what's going on at the
moment they have advised the BBC to
pause its investigation which for those
reasons alone the BBC were were not
forthcoming if you like really and
giving much information about what they
have ascertained really with with this
case they have though published a
timeline of exactly uh who knew what
when which you have already set out but
but look the investigations team that
they explain how they swung into action
the amount of times they tried to to
verify uh the complainant that
um that had approached them it doesn't
make for particularly sort of reassuring
reading of how the investigations team
had swung into action so on the 18th of
May the complainant came to the BBC to
make these claims about this unnamed
presenter on the 19th of May the
corporate investigations team were
alerted they ascertained that this was
serious enough for them to look into but
they didn't decide at that stage that
anything criminal had taken place so
basically the process that that happened
was all about verifying the identity not
of the young person in question but of
the people that were making the
complaint and in doing so they sent an
email on the 19th of May didn't do
anything else until the 6th of June when
they made a phone call which were told
didn't connect and then after that it
appears that while the case remained
open nothing happened until on the 6th
of July a whole month later the Sun
newspaper then published its allegations
and then they swing into action if you
like
um but certainly the the delays and just
verifying the identity of the people
that were making the complaints
certainly does Merit uh the process of
the director General has now said which
will look into how complaints are are
red flagged
um so the BBC investigation has been
paused
um
what we what we know though is that
several several questions were put to
the director General about why the
presenter remains are named whether or
not they are prepared that perhaps
underprivileged the presenter might end
up being named in Parliament the
director General said
because of a duty of care they are
considering things like the impact that
would have and the impact on the
presenters privacy but they were also
taken into account the public interest
of things like that but Tim Davey said
that it would be unwise to go through
various scenarios of what may or may not
happen he wouldn't be drawn on whether
or not any other people have come forth
to make complaints about the presenters
since this he also uh he was asked
whether or not he had spoken to the
presenter in question and he said put
simply no
um and he said he wouldn't go into the
specifics of whether or not the
presenter now is being given any sort of
package of support but he said as a
corporation on the whole they do provide
excellent levels of assistant for for
anyone because they have these duty of
care steps in place but really I mean I
think the shocking thing is that that
timeline while we now know that the
investigations team looking into this
we're taking this seriously
the detail that they go into of how
quickly they they acted or didn't by all
accounts it is quite shocking to see
that it doesn't seem like Beyond an
email and one phone call which didn't
connect they didn't seem to do a lot
really here
yeah I mean Tim Davies faced uh grilling
as you said it's supposed to be about
the BBC's accounts wasn't it yet having
to answer rather uncomfortable questions
it will have to be said about this
present around
beauty of care and how they uh do
believe it would be
um unwise to kind of go into any of
specifics of what exactly that is
alleged to have happened now
particularly given that they have been
asked by the police to pause any
investigation that is happening
internally at this stage
um but we know from the from the the Met
police as well they themselves haven't
said that any criminal investigation has
taken place more that they are now
taking this sort of overarching view
stepping back and assessing the
information that they have been given so
are we in a sort of limbo situation here
where we we don't it doesn't appear that
the police really are acting on anything
but equally the BBC now have this reason
and that they say that they they won't
be taking it further for now so I
honestly I do think that Tim Davey
probably does have to to spend a bit
more time talking to journalists on this
and explaining exactly what's going on
because we are no clearer if you like of
what is happening now and what the next
steps will be for the BBC other than the
fact that they have admitted if you like
the the process the red flag process of
raising these uh issues when they come
up perhaps that now does need to be
reviewed that's one lesson to be learned
if you like they've admitted yes Tim
Davey admitting to to a number of
failures it would seem I wonder then
what does happen next I guess nobody
knows if the investigation or certainly
on the BBC's side pauses things have
been moving quite rapidly haven't they
the last couple of days but what happens
now
well look it would seem that the BBC are
trying to pass the put the ball uh
setting the ball in the court of the
police now they're certainly saying that
because the the police has it's been
handed over to them and the police have
said that now uh it is they are looking
into this and they don't want the BBC uh
to uh well they want the BBC to pause
their internal uh investigation and
because of that uh it would seem the BBC
certainly can't continue to to with
their own investigation
um but look I mean if you take that
timeline of just how slow they were to
act with their internal investigation in
the first place they could really have
done with swinging into action a lot
more quickly than they did I mean in
some defense that they offered in
mitigation if you like to to why the
investigation teams didn't go beyond
sort of sending this email and carrying
out a phone call what they did say is
that the investigation teams was kind of
in the process of dealing with over 200
other complaints that had made to them
so this is the process that they have to
put every sort of complaint that comes
to them through they have to verify the
person that's making the complainant the
complaint before they actually approach
the person in question because as well
the presenter in question don't forget
wasn't contacted by the BBC until last
week we know from the timeline that they
have now given us that yeah the
presentering question wasn't approached
prior to the sun publishing their
article
and that was the thrust wasn't it of the
complaint originally by the mother who
who went to the sun saying that she
hadn't heard from the BBC and it seems
that is now born out by this timeline on
the 19th of May and now it's become
clear a phone call was made according to
the BBC on the 6th of June which didn't
connect
I mean that that is the thing that sort
of leaves you with your mouth open
really in that respect that uh that on
the timeline it is noted that the phone
call did not connect did they not have
time to go back and retry trying to
phone the the parents it's I mean as
investigation teams go you would
question really why you would not return
to send multiple emails why would you
not return and make multiple phone calls
but going by this timeline that the BBC
has published it certainly is a a bit
weak to say the least really the
response that the investigations team
made for the first few weeks until the
sun went to press with its article which
I mean we know from what the the family
of this young person in question have
said is they weren't satisfied with the
response they got from the BBC that's
why they went to the papers because they
didn't seem to be getting any response
for the BBC and you can understand why
really given that it didn't seem like
it's going timeline the BBC did anything
does this do for the reputation of the
BBC
oh it's incredibly damaging for the BBC
I mean as well they started the Press
briefing by talking about what a
successful year this has been for the
BBC with some Landmark moments that
stand out I was talking about things
like the the Jubilee how the The Queen's
funeral as well just moments that
they've found to brag about and be
triumphant about in in how it's handled
its own sort of program making in the
last year but actually I think if we're
talking about moments in the last year
the BBC has stood out this will go down
as one of the biggest moments for the
BBC this year because it is handled this
complaint so appallingly by all accounts
and it doesn't seem to be doing a
particularly good job in explaining
exactly what the delay was I mean even
now that we've had this briefing from
Tim Davey and just briefly Casey do you
think heads might have to roll at the
BBC given the admission of these
failures
I think it's hard to say you know I mean
they're coming under an incredible
amount of political pressure it will be
I guess for the politicians because this
is a public service broadcaster
answerable to taxpayers I think it will
be uh whether or not that political
pressure continues to be placed on the
BBC at the moment though
um certainly just going from that
briefing that that was given to
journalists it didn't I didn't come away
with feeling that there was a
satisfactory explanation for why the BBC
took so long in investigating this I
mean uh just just the weakness in the
fact that it seems to have just been one
email one phone call for an
investigations team that is meant to be
swift this is an establishment that has
protocols in place safeguarding
protocols it has
um sort of triumphantly heralded in the
last 10 years following the awful
scandals of things like Jimmy Savile it
said it's changed it said it's got these
robust protocols in place and yet here
are and if you if they're thinking this
timeline will sort of dampen out the the
Flames I mean this timeline just makes
them look like they really weren't on
the ball with this so we'll head's roll
I think certainly it doesn't end the
conversation this
all right Katie many thanks indeed for
now following developments very closely
there Katie Spencer joining me in the
studio is the media lawyer and Matthew
Gill well fairly fast moving isn't it
the last day or so that this whole
process and admission there from Tim
Davey uh the director general of the BBC
that the corporation has failed in in
certain respects given given that time
now given the delays uh given that an
email was sent on the the 19th then no
further action was taken and this is new
on the 6th of June uh which was around a
month before the article appeared in the
paper a phone call was made that didn't
connect and then well by all intents and
purposes forgotten about it does seem
odd that there was a a pause or a stop
in this investigation when only a couple
of contacts have been attempted contacts
have been made and and it seemed to have
been stopped or paused there I mean the
statement says that it was still open
and that seems to infer that if there
had been further contact from the family
the BBC would have picked it up but it
is unclear whether actually they dropped
the ball on this yeah um but if the BBC
had come out and sort of explained it in
a way of Mayor culpa um certain failures
it's still got more questions to answer
really hasn't it that given given these
Stark admissions I think you're right I
think they have got more questions
questions to answer but they also say in
their statement that they are open
they're prepared to answer those
questions they've asked
um someone inside the BBC to look into
the policies and the processes and
whether they have failed here and
whether they need to be improved in
future well stay with us we'll obviously
follow this during the course of the
hour this breaking news which I shall
remind you about this timeline which has
just broken at midday so let's take you
through what happened and when on the
18th of May the family member attended a
BBC building and tried to make a
complaint about the unnamed presenter of
course that presenter still is unnamed
but has been suspended the following day
the complainant contacted audience
services that complaint was passed to
the BBC's corporate investigations team
now the investigations team decided
there was no criminal allegation but
that the claims needed further
investigation but got no response to an
email sent to a family member on June
the 6th this is a new date a phone call
was made to the complainant but did not
connect according to the BBC then no
further attempts were made to make
contact now a month later the sun
informed the BBC about the allegations
which were different in nature to the
original claims that is something that
came out from the BBC last week this was
the first time the director general or
any executive directors at the BBC were
aware of the case
a senior manager had the first
conversation with the presenter that
very day and it was agreed that the
presenter would not be on air then the
next day the BBC's investigations team
then contacted the complainant again and
the BBC made contact with the police the
fact is the presenter was suspended on
Sunday and yesterday the BBC bosses met
with police to discuss the investigation
and have now paused their inquiry while
the police look into their claims let's
speak to the media commentator and
former News of the World Deputy editor
Neil Wallace joining us live on the
program thank you for your time today
what do you make of these Stark
admissions then from the BBC
well I thought initially the BBC were
handling this quite well they are very
successfully turning this into a
disaster
and I cannot begin to imagine the
mindset that would uh the complacency
that would allow them to have complaints
like this on their desks and basically
do nothing about it that they sat there
and
despite the seriousness of what was
being said here whether they were
technically legal uh or not the alleged
offenses at the time
does not change the fact that for the
BBC this was very serious allegations
and yet they sat on their hands and did
nothing and just ignored the situation
and hoped it would go away this is the
very worst
of the BBC isn't it and really it you
can be of course confident that no heads
will ever roll on these things because
they don't at the BBC but
um sometimes they do eventually don't
sometimes they do eventually don't they
well I only very senior level when
they're directly
culpable usually yeah but this is where
this is where it goes now to senior
level isn't it because uh Tim Davies had
to come out and explain who knew what
and when
but I think that Tim Davey is now trying
to pick up pieces uh from a disaster
that has been sat there for a month on
somebody's desk the idea that the a
presenter of this level could have
allegations of this level aimed at them
and they not proactively pursue this the
idea that because a telephone didn't
contact once that was it they just
walked away I just think he's shocking
and just brings back the feeling of
complacency that has cursed the BBC in
its handling of uh internal problems
does it come down to complacency then
I fear it does yeah I I think it's what
you see very often across
um the public Serv Public Service which
is effectively what the BBC is but what
we need to remember here
there are a couple of parents who are
fighting desperately they tell us uh to
deal with their child's
um shall we say health problems the
allegations that this child is a crack
addict
these are the people who are the victims
in this and I I've been following the
BBC coverage this morning I've been
taking part in some of it and I find it
very disturbing the way there's this The
Narrative is being swung around to
somehow they have failed they have
desperately fought for their child and
you know that's who the real victims are
in this don't let's
um worry too much about whether or not
the BBC uh are feeling a bit badly
treated because they simply aren't I
mean it has to be said nobody does know
what went on especially as this lawyer
for the young person came out and said
all the allegations are untrue no
unlawful Act was committed uh how
interesting isn't it this
um apparently very vulnerable young
person has somehow ended up with uh a
Belgravia based International lawyer uh
whose fees will be up there uh in the
hundreds upon hundreds of pounds a day
how they are paying for that who knows
but when you actually look at the same
which of course has not yet been fully
released
only a partial bit of it has been
released but as I understand it it does
not address the issue were there
photographs where what kind of
photographs were they was money paid
over it seems to be oh nothing to see
here uh there was nothing illegal
and that seems to be it well not being
illegal is not the same as being immoral
or inappropriate or wrong
and that's where this needs to go to and
the BBC simply can't turn away and say
that there's nothing to see here go well
questions are being asked to the BBC
quite rightly but shouldn't questions be
asked to the sun and the journalism
given the fact that apparently we're led
to believe this uh lawyer came out
before the article was published and
said it is not true
the lawyer said no I think you missed
you're muddling things up what okay
there is some allegation that there was
a WhatsApp message sent by the
vulnerable child the vulnerable young
person uh late on the Friday night
and whether or not that was discernible
bearing in mind the conditions uh that
this is all happening in that the
vulnerabilities of that person maybe
it's not quite as as easy to categorize
as that what we do know is that there is
sufficient seriousness here that uh Tim
Davies who I think has been a proactive
and a good uh director General is taking
steps he says this is very serious he
knows the idea that one of his most
famous most senior presenters
is caught up in this and there is no
denial as yet no specific denial that
money has been paid very large sums of
money tens of thousands of pounds of
money has been paid to a young person
who according to their parents they're
worried frantic parents has developed a
dangerous crack addiction
that's what matters in this
that's what happens what what should
happen to the presenter now given the
fact that the BBC has paused its
investigation while the police in their
words scope this and look into it but
but you see this this is exactly what
they should not be doing because the
fact is if the police decide to
investigate this it will take months
there will be no quick resolution as far
as the police are concerned they will be
talking a long long time examining if
they decide to get involved because it
is quite a difficult area because it's
on the cusp who knows what happened
exactly at what point
um there's no quick resolution by
standing by and saying well let's just
say it's a policies problem this is the
BBC's problem it is their presenter they
need to be asking and finding out what
happened when was money paid over were
pictures uh exchanged how did this come
about when did it begin
all of these questions are extremely
significant and are extremely valid and
you know somehow diverting attention to
all the police are the admitted or
saying oh well did the sun do this or do
that all we know is for certain that a
couple of concerned parents who have
neither asked for money nor been given
it have been trying to get the BBC to
get this presenter sending the alleged
large watches of money
do you think the BBC's passed the box or
what by pausing this investigation then
I do yeah I do I I think it's quite
shocking
um I I think the idea that you know
somebody can patiently sit back and say
well it's off our hands it's not don't
forget this presenter is paid by my
money and your money and your viewers
money this is significant it is not like
um I do think it's a BBC version of the
uh Scofield situation on ITV but I think
it's much more serious because this is a
BBC and because
to be brutal about it the BBC have a
track record of complacency you and I
will remember the Jimmy Savile inquiry
there were many attempts to uh deal with
the Germany civil inquiry that never got
off the ground and there was he even
attempt to do an investigation by I
think it was either news night or
Panorama that was stalled because it was
Jimmy Savile a major major
front-facing personality of the BBC well
again we've got a very powerful very
high profile
presenter on the BBC and they cannot
just turn a blind eye and hope it goes
away they've tried that before it didn't
work it won't work this time either
all right Neil Wallace thank you very
much indeed if your time it's good to
get your thoughts on this breaking story
let's talk about the political Dimension
to this because the Prime Minister was
forced to comment on the story as he
landed in Lithuania for a two-day NATO
Summit where she sunak said the
allegations were shocking and concerning
however in an indication of how quickly
all this is moving and has been the last
few hours he spoke of the need for a
quick BBC investigation of course we now
know that has been paused by the
corporation while they say please decide
the next steps let's talk to our
political correspondent Ali fortiscu so
the Prime Minister Ali asked a number of
questions clearly he wanted the NATO
Summit to be on the front of his mind
but he's asked two questions about the
BBC investigation which we now know has
been paused so uh bringing in every uh
wing of Society including politicians
yeah that's right and I mean look the
relationship between the government and
BBC is always interesting and I guess
somewhat fragile but what we saw today
was a prime minister I think wanting to
distance
um but I don't think he did I don't
think he necessarily wanted to be
answering questions on this and what
we've seen from ministers over the last
few days is
um you know a blame really being
directed at the BBC saying that it is
down to them to investigate this the
prime minister's saying the BBC need to
investigate rigorously and rapidly
um saying that it is seriously
concerning
um we had Alex troch the Justice
secretary yesterday saying the BBC needs
to get its house in order obviously you
know the events have overtaken things
somewhat because now uh we have the news
that the BBC investigation has been
paused
um at the police request so the prime
minister's comments um seem a bit old
now because um the BBC can't investigate
this rigorously and wrap rapidly as he
suggested I think the other question
that politicians are facing is
um concern over parliamentary privilege
being used to name the the presenter at
the center of this Scandal and that is
something that protects MPS uh from
being sued for defamation if they were
to name this individual in the House of
Commons and it's been used previously
for example with um Philip Green in 2018
uh over reported allegations of a
businessman
um allegedly
acting inappropriately or misconduct so
that is a concern that was put to the
Prime Minister today he clearly didn't
want to comment on it worth saying
though um his spokesperson earlier did
say that
um the freedom of speech is obviously an
important thing but this is a sensitive
matter and that the investigation
um is continuing so I think the
government obviously very keen to say
that this is a BBC issue has been dealt
with being investigated that it is
concerning but it needs to be dealt with
rapidly but obviously events have moved
on now and we know um that the BBC
investigation has been paused
um at the police's request
many people speculating of course that
who the I what the identity of this
presenter is who has been suspended Ali
and uh speaking to K Burley this morning
the work and pension secretary Mel
stride was cautioning wasn't he against
her naming uh this individual in
Parliament and uh and uh which
politicians are entitled to do under
parliamentary privilege yeah exactly so
these are very old
um kind of rules uh it's quite peculiar
in a way that MPS you know it has as I
say been used before not just with
Philip green we're saying um with Ryan
Giggs two uh the footballer uh who had
an injunction that was um suddenly it
came up under parliamentary privilege as
well so it's a way that MPS can bring
things up without
um facing the same risk of being sued
for defamation
um but as I say that was something I
think the Prime Minister didn't really
want to talk about today and as you were
saying
Rishi sunak is on the world stage today
he's at the NATO Summit he wants to be
he's in Lithuania he wants to be talking
about Ukraine that is somewhere
um the world stage you know Foreign
Affairs is a place where number 10 think
that the Prime Minister looks at ease
does pretty well compared to you know
the trouble back home the five pledges
that he's struggling with
um so that's what he wants to be talking
about but instead you know this is a
story that has dominated uh the
headlines and these questions continue
to swirl and the prime minister is
having to answer questions about the be
this BBC crisis but
um is clearly trying to point the finger
at the BBC and saying that they're the
ones that need to be investigating this
rapidly as he said this morning and
rigorously
Ali for now thank you very much indeed
Ali Fortescue their media lawyer Matthew
Gill is with us if you can see on the
screen the corporations admitting in
recent days uh the case is complex and
challenging
um Tim Davey when pushed clearly did he
not admit to a series of failures that
the BBC looked at a complaint on the
19th we'll go through the timeline in a
moment the 19th of May an email was sent
and a phone call was made on the 6th of
June which didn't connect
and something's gone seriously wrong
here hasn't it when this is supposed to
be looked at by what is called the
corporate investigations team I I think
I think Tim Davey is doing his best to
be as open as possible here within the
constraints of the law and that's really
difficult the key piece of information
that we don't know right now is what
allegations were made by the family at
the outset of this uh complaint compared
to what they what the allegations are
now and because you can imagine if the
allegations were a lot less serious at
the beginning perhaps that warranted the
approach that we have seen which
involved you know a phone call and an
email to the family to follow up on
their questions we simply don't know
what the complaint was at the beginning
and Tim Davey is restricted in what he
can say about it what he has said though
is that there will be an investigation
within the BBC into whether their
policies and processes have been
followed here and and whether they could
be improved in future because because he
acknowledges that there is concern that
there's been a failure of of process all
right thank you Matthew for now we'll
come back to you a little later
um good afternoon to you this is Sky
News Today just after half past 12 on
Tuesday lunchtime Nick Croatia with you
bringing you our breaking news this
afternoon which I shall remind you about
now the director general of the BBC has
admitted the corporation must learn
lessons about how complaints of red
flagged after it emerged no senior
executive or even the presenter who has
been suspended was told about the
allegations until seven weeks after they
were made in the past hour the
corporation's boss answered questions
about the presenter Scandal which is
rocking the organization let's bring in
Skye's home editor Jason Farrell who is
outside the headquarters of the BBC new
Broadcasting House in central London so
it seems at this lunchtime Jason more
questions than answers for the BBC
well we've certainly had some answers um
but we haven't had all the answers that
I think we would like we've had this
timeline from the BBC which starts on
the 18th of May when a family member
turned up at a PVC building to make a
complaint they were told to go through
the corporate Communications to uh to to
put in their complaint in writing they
was they did that that was received and
an email was sent back and it should be
said at this point it was assessed as a
serious allegation what the BBC are
saying is that it wasn't assessed later
as uh showing criminality but just to
continue with the timeline at this stage
um the BBC said they didn't get a
response to the email that they sent to
the complainants so they left it to June
the 6th so about a week later a bit
longer they make a phone call and they
say that that phone call didn't connect
um they say that the case wasn't closed
they kept it open and it was due to be
followed up but it it clearly hadn't
been followed up for another month I
think that's one of the serious concerns
about this I think another clear concern
is that the whoever the senior presenter
was wasn't contacted by anyone and asked
about the allegations so they haven't
been able to get hold of the people
making the allegations they hadn't asked
the presenter and and they hadn't made
many attempts to follow up
following one phone call that didn't
connect and then a month later the
article appears in the Sun newspaper and
it is only then that the presenter is is
spoken to but again it doesn't we don't
get the sense that um from what we were
hearing from the director General Tim
Davey that that presenter was then asked
for example to provide Bank details or
evidence or anything like that we're not
we're not getting a disclosure of what
was said by the presenter for reasons of
Duty of care and and confidentiality
um but we we then know that they did
then the BBC did then make contact with
the complainants and some details have
been handed over to the BBC some
supporting evidence that the family
believe is supporting evidence has been
handed over to the BBC and we know of
course that BBC then met with the police
yesterday
and that the police haven't said they're
launching an investigation they
specifically said they're not launching
an investigation but they are doing a
scoping exercise and whilst they're
doing that they've asked the BBC to
pause their investigation
and so that's where the BBC is up to at
this stage they can't do anything else
because they can't trample over what
what the what the police might decide to
do so at the moment it stays with the
police
um but they do say Obviously a further
details come into them for example if
there's another complaint about the
presenter or anyone else obviously they
will take that seriously and if
necessary pass that on to the police so
uh they're not completely closed down on
it but at this stage they're not doing
anything further
I think the real big questions that come
out of this and this is the question
that I asked the director General and I
have to say that this is asked over Zoom
so my question is put in as a written
question and it's asked by someone from
the BBC to the direct generals it can't
be followed up with a follow-up question
but the question I suggested was well
look you've been accused of Lying by the
family they say that what they said on
May the 19th was exactly what's been
said in the Sun newspaper so I asked how
does it differ how exactly does what you
received on the 19th of May differ from
what was published in the sun because we
all know what was published in the Sun
so what was missing from what was said
on May the 19th and what we got back
from the director General was that their
assessors assessed that it wasn't
Criminal I wasn't quite clear to me
whether the BBC still stand by that
having looked back at the complaint and
they they still feel that you know what
is that different I think that's the
thing that people hoped might be
clarified in this a little bit more
clearly than it was
all right Jason for that many thanks
indeed our home editor Jason Farrell
joining us there uh we are joined Now by
Steve Barnett professor of
communications at the University of
Westminster and author of the battle for
the BBC a British Broadcasting
conspiracy good to have you on the
program today do you feel the BBC has
been getting a bit of breathing space
now if this investigation has paused and
do they need it
well I I'm I'm slightly bemused that the
focus is almost entirely on the BBC
because
um if you look at the Timeline that
we've heard about this morning it seems
to me that the BBC that receives
hundreds of complaints every single day
um yeah many actually quite spurious
um as soon as this complaint was put
into writing the next day they asked for
more details and received nothing in
reply they then tried the phone number
that the complainant had given them a
couple of weeks later and the phone
number didn't connect and it's difficult
to know if there were allegations that
were made in the BBC try to find out
more about them what else they could
have done under the circumstances again
remembering that we get they get
hundreds of complaints every single day
um and I I I'm just I'm still struggling
because it you know that your reports
keep talking about the family let's
remember that the young person involved
in this denies the allegations being
made by their mother and stepfather so
there is a a clear disjunction between
the young person involved and the
complainants so the family are not at
one on this and I think we have to be
very careful about jumping to
conclusions and making judgments that
somehow the BBC has to be in the
spotlight on its own of course there are
questions and that is fair enough
um nobody knows what happened
allegations
and and his lawyer or sorry their lawyer
we don't know the gender of this person
have denied so are we back to square one
I mean many people listening to this the
the fact is that a phone call was made
but they're not followed up however it
was in the hands of the BBC's corporate
investigations team which by the very
nature and the sound of it sounds like a
a big group of people trying to get to
the bottom of something well if if the
validation's made and they made attempts
to get in touch with the complainants
but we're getting nothing back
then it's difficult to know what else
they could have done now you know we're
we're all of us grappling around in the
dark here and it's quite appropriate
that there should be proper
investigation do you ask whether the BBC
has a breathing space yes it does I
don't think it particularly wants a
breathing space I think the BBC would
actually love to get on with an internal
inquiry that finds out exactly who knew
what did they act appropriately and with
appropriate speed and were their
internal protocols followed but they've
been asked by the police to pause that
inquiry so they don't have any choice
and in the meantime we don't know any of
these facts all we do know is that there
is a disagreement between the young
person involved and their parents and
yet it seems to me that nothing is being
asked of the newspaper that has been
pursuing an anti-bbc agenda for decades
has a proprietor that loathes the BBC
and and this is a story that is being
driven by a set of disputed facts which
is putting the BBC under the spotlight
but not the sun's journalism
you'll understand the Focus right now is
on the BBC given the fact that Tim Davey
has answered questions via zoom in the
past hour so how has the BBC handled
this whole matter well I think they've
handled it in in in a way that I mean
the bcpc is in a very very difficult
position these are very sensitive
matters they are a matters involving you
know a young person who can't be
identified a presenter who can't be
identified neither of whom should be
identified because at the moment these
are as I say allegations and disputed
allegations so they are both entitled to
their privacy
um can I also say by the way
um to just almost as an aside if any MP
does abuse their parliamentary privilege
by naming the presenter I think that
will be an absolute disgrace because
there is no public interest in this I
understand people be curious and most
people have been online probably know
the allegations being made but there is
no public interest in revealing the name
of the presenter while these
investigations are ongoing and I
sincerely hope any MP who does that will
simply be doing it for their own
self-promotion and self-aggrandement and
I sincerely hope that they exercise a
little bit of restraint but just coming
back to your your question I think the
BBC has handled this as
um as as adequately as it can possibly
do under the circumstances bearing in
mind their duty of care to the young
person involved and to the presenter
involved and given the the disputes that
are being involved and the fact that the
police have now asked them to pause
their investigation it's quite difficult
to know what else they could have done
I'm sure Tim Dave is right I'm sure
there will be lessons that can be
learned there always are but to suggest
that the BBC has been wrong or slow or
inappropriate I'm afraid is frankly in
my view just to to pre-judge what is
being investigated now and more
importantly to follow the sun's anti-bbc
agenda
okay thank you very much indeed nice to
talk to you Steve Barnett professor of
communications there at the University
of Westminster in the studio with me now
is the media lawyer Matthew Gill so let
me put that to you how do you think the
the BBC's handle the whole matter I tend
to agree it's really too early to
rejudge how they've handled the matter
because there are so many unknowns we
still don't know what the original
complaints contained and that will be
the most important piece of information
in this jigsaw I think because if it
turns out that the allegations were very
similar to the ones reported in the sun
we might be more critical of the BBC's
handling but if they were of a very
different nature then then you might
understand that they would have taken a
different course
yeah
um let's talk about the presenter for a
moment uh Steve Barnett there was saying
there's no public interest in naming
this man is that something you agree
with I do tend to agree that there isn't
a public interest right now in naming a
BBC presenter when the allegations about
him are disputed and they they are
heavily disputed by uh allegedly the the
key participants
um and so it would be premature I'm
really uh you know significantly
damaging to this BBC presenter's
reputation if he were to be named at
this stage
I suppose some of the heat is off the
BBC at the moment I mean
many will as our guest was saying there
give him his due Tim Davey has held his
hands up to some of the failings at the
corporation uh there or what are
perceived to be uh failings but now
given what we know the last 24 hours
statement from the lawyer on behalf of
this young person and the disputed
claims a number of organizations will
now have to be under investigation
really I I think there will be certainly
internal investigations that many of the
uh you know the BBC and probably also at
the sun into what has happened and
whether they got things right
um I think it's right that the BBC
clearly allow the police to uh start con
you know their scoping work they
describe it not an investigation but to
scope these issues and the BBC stop one
because uh the police have asked them to
um and two because if there are criminal
issues at play here it's clearly right
that the police investigate those before
any internal investigation and what
criminal Avenues could potentially be
pursued by the police they're clearly
looking into this now I understand that
the the main criminal Avenue that uh has
been alleged is that
um it's illegal to possess uh indecent
images of under 18s and there is some
suggestion that the young person
involved may have been under 18 at the
time that clearly is a different
threshold to the legal age of consent
which is 16. and that's where there is
some confusion around this topic
um but but that's where there could be
criminal liability
um if the allegations are found to be
true all right for now thank you very
much indeed um let's turn to former BBC
journalist and founder of the broadcast
Academy Kerry Hopkins hello to you so
what about this breaking news and the
BBC admitted that it uh things should
have been better processes should have
been improved red flagged incidents uh
per se and also this timeline which many
people will find interesting the fact
that a complaint was made on the 18th of
May that an email was sent and then this
phone call on the 6th of June which was
made but then it didn't connect and that
then according it seems to the the
mother is why she contacted the son
yes I mean good sort of reacting in a
good way when it comes to crisis comes
needs to be done very quickly and I
think it's great that Tim Davey has
released this timeline just now because
now it's answering some questions that
have been going on for the last few days
I think actually originally
um given that the complain and contacted
the BBC and the BBC contacted the
complainer roughly within 24 hours later
is reacting pretty quickly and Tim Davey
did say today that the original email
didn't sort of say anything
that was illegal
so maybe that's why they haven't reacted
as quickly but I think lessons will be
learned that they need to perhaps
escalate this to Tim Davey much sooner
even if it doesn't sound like it's
illegal on the face of it to sort of do
you see where I'm coming from well I
suppose as one of our guests was saying
the BBC have hundreds of of complaints
sometimes it may be said that it's hard
to know
what is genuine but but do you think in
an organization if a complaint has been
made against a specific individual which
must have happened here seven weeks
before the presenter in question was
contacted and was spoken to
that does seem a very long time to wait
to talk to the individual in question
absolutely
um I think you know this is the BBC have
well in organizations that are as large
as the BBC there are undoubtedly a lot
of people doing
things that you know might be considered
unethical or illegal and in this case
you know certainly we don't know the
facts I'm certainly not saying that
anyone has acted like that at the moment
um but the BBC have had a lot of you
know negative press recently and this
isn't just in the UK they've got the BBC
Studios which are operating all around
the world so the BBC's a brand across
the world so this you know it's in the
Washington Post it's in the New York
Times it's in el pay in Spain I was
reading on the way here so the
reputation of the BBC in the UK is
different to the way it's seen worldwide
so they can more or less take it or
leave it compared to us which you know
because it's a public service
broadcaster so this is certainly news
that Tim Davey and the BBC won't want
right now particularly because they'll
have the launch of new films new new TV
shows from BBC Studios that that really
if they're doing that right now the
question on the journalist slips isn't
going to be a new film or a new TV show
it's going to be what is the story here
you know what's the truth what are you
doing about it yeah I mean he should
have expected to face these questions
shouldn't he rather than going on about
appraising the BBC for for it in its
annual report how how successful it's
been absolutely yes
and um do you think heads might have to
roll at the BBC given that the delays
and and the clear admission here certain
things have failed
well I think it's still a difficult
story because you've got the well we
don't know if it is true or not whether
so if you're under 18 receiving or if
somebody's under 18 receiving or sending
illicit photos is illegal
so the allegations that this person
started talking to this presenter age 17
but were photos sent at that point or
did they wait till they're 18 of which
no uh crime has been committed so I
think until more
um
two more more to this story comes to
light it's really hard to say at this
stage
all right thank you very much indeed
it's nice to get your thoughts Kerry
Hopkins there back to Matthew Gill media
lawyer so we've chewed over this for
about an hour now haven't we he's quite
startling admissions from the BBC but as
we heard there from one of our guests
BBC's in a no-win situation and feels
they've handled it the whole matter
correctly what what's your assessments
yeah I think they say look there were
allegations that the BBC had you know
completely failed to contact the family
once the complaint had been made and I
think the reason that Tim Davey has put
this statement out today is to try and
combat that narrative to point out that
actually they did try to contact the
family once the complaint had been made
and that they they were following a
process and procedures and that the
investigation was still open and what
has what's come to light and what I
think people are
um zeroing in on is is the is the point
that there was a seven week gap between
the last attempt to contact with the
family and the allegations being
published in the Sun that has triggered
the the publicity around this allegation
that we've seen and I think that's where
people are concerned and the BBC are
certainly going to have to look at
whether in future they should be doing
better to investigate allegations
um when when they've been brought to
them why do you think the presenter
wasn't spoken to I mean clearly from
what we've heard this complaint that was
made on the 18th of May was serious
there is no according to the BBC no
allegation of criminality but if
somebody leveled a serious allegation
against me for instance wouldn't your
boss wouldn't this uh corporate
investigations team at the BBC be
wanting to to speak to your to your star
it seems like um the BBC contacted the
family the day after the complaint was
formally made and they asked for more
information and it may have been that
they felt that they needed to understand
in Greater detail the allegation before
they would go to the presenter with it
we don't know in what detail the
complaint was initially made and you can
imagine that if there was a a very short
worded allegation that the BBC do have
to draw a line between the allegations
that they will take to their staff
members and others that they might
decide are
um potentially spurious or lacking
detail in order to cause a problem by
bringing it to their their staff members
it's a really difficult balance and the
BBC chose on this occasion not to tell
the presenter we might find that they
take a different approach going forward
it's not at the moment it would seem as
they have paused their investigation is
that is that something usual because the
police are involved looking into as
they're in their words scoping this
investigation I think that's absolutely
usual
um ultimately if the police asked you to
stop your internal investigation most
employers would do as they're told
um but also I think it's right that
since the family have suggested there
might have been criminality or at least
the allegations they've made have raised
that possibility I'm sure the family
would want the police to investigate
them rather than the BBC in the first
instance and so I think it's right that
where there are allegations of
criminality the police go first and and
no doubt the BBC will uh pursue an
internal investigation once the police
have given them the the all clear to do
so and do you think this suspended
presenter will ever be named or
certainly in in the coming days and is
there any reason to name him I don't
imagine that the presenter will be named
in the coming days I think the police
went together with the BBC's you know
the investigation they've progressed
already
um we'll need to establish a greater
amount of facts so we need to speak to
the relevant parties and look through
documents before they can
um come to a conclusion as to whether
there is a significant amount of facts
or sufficient amount of facts to justify
naming the presenter in this case